antes de empezar quiero haceros un
anuncio muy especial estamos en año de
mundial así que hemos querido preparar
algo super novedoso en el canal en
visual política algo que creemos os va a
encantar la liga visual política
de la mano de nuestros amigos de wenger
hemos puesto en marcha una liga fantasy
donde podremos competir entre todos
participar en la liga visual política es
algo muy sencillo y por supuesto
totalmente gratuito y además podéis
conseguir premios simplemente tenéis que
seguir el enlace que os dejamos en los
comentarios y en la descripción graves
os descarguéis la app de be wenger si es
que no la tenéis ya os llevará
directamente a nuestra liga entonces tan
sólo tendréis que asignar un nombre a
vuestro equipo y listo ya estaréis
preparados para gestionar vuestro propio
equipo y enfrentaros a fonseca a couto
iam y empezaréis con un equipo aleatorio
y un presupuesto con el que podréis
fichar jugadores por ejemplo lo que se
confía es en la campaña que hará
lewandowski queréis que benzema volverá
a salirse otro año más pues ya sabes por
supuesto también podrás vender jugadores
para hacer caja porque esto es
importante siempre siempre tendrás que
tener las cuentas en positivo para poder
puntuar así que ya sabes perfila tu
plantilla escoge tu alineación tu
capitán y empecemos
es crees que podrás derrotar al equipo
de visual político pues venga apuntaros
a la liga visual política en beat wenger
y preparados para competir
[Aplausos]
[Música]
la popularidad del presidente
norteamericano joe biden está por los
suelos bueno que digo por los suelos se
ha hundido de tal forma que
prácticamente podemos decir que se está
sumergiendo en las fosas más profundas
del océano electoral prestar mucha
atención a los datos a mediados de julio
del 2022 algunas encuestas sugerían que
el
71% de los votantes no querían que se
volviera a presentar incluido el 54% de
los demócratas un porcentaje este último
que se incrementa hasta el 94 por ciento
entre los jóvenes demócratas dentro de
18 y 29 años el
94% la casa blanca se enfrenta a un
desastre con los votantes jóvenes cada
vez más temores entre los demócratas de
que estén en peligro de perder una
generación sino mejorar su posición ante
la generación z y eso no es todo si
tomamos una media de encuestas podemos
ver que el nivel de aprobación del
presidente no deja de caer tal y como
podéis ver desde su toma de posesión en
apenas un año y medio su nivel de
aprobación ha caído 20 puntos una locura
pero cómo es esto posible que explica
semejante debacle en la valoración
presidente
[Música]
pero volviendo al vaivén si somos justos
desde la caótica indigna y desastrosa
forma en la que se produjo la retirada
de afganistán algo que aquí en visual
polític criticamos duramente el equipo
formado por el presidente vayan el
secretario de estado anthony blinken y
el secretario de defensa lloyd austin ha
cosechado bastantes tantos en política
exterior y no me refiero a tantos
precisamente pequeños por ejemplo estos
tres personajes están liderando el apoyo
norteamericano y occidental a ucrania de
una guerra que ha desbaratado por
completo los planes del kremlin y que ha
destrozado una buena parte de la
capacidad militar rusa también han sido
capaces de consolidar y cohesionar tanto
la otan como la relación atlántica de
hecho con byd en washington ha vuelto a
ser todo un líder en el viejo continente
y hoy la organización del tratado del
atlántico norte parece más fuerte que
nunca y no se trata sólo de la vieja
europa en asia está ocurriendo tres
cuartas partes de lo mismo
la política firme de esta administración
ha desbordado ha superado por completo
las ambiciones chinas de hacerse con la
hegemonía regional por ejemplo ahí
tenemos los casos del programa caucus
que busca hacer de australia una
superpotencia o el fortalecimiento de
las relaciones con japón y corea del sur
este último dándole por cierto plena
libertad para el desarrollo de misiles
balísticos también podemos mencionar la
reiterada defensa de taiwán la mejora de
las relaciones bilaterales entre los
aliados de eeuu en la zona del
fortalecimiento del quad y el nuevo
marco económico del indo pacífico
pues hemos hablado de todo ello en un
pasado vídeo aquí en visual político la
actividad de la administración bailén en
el pacífico está siendo casi tan
frenética como en europa pero es que
incluso en oriente medio donde las
relaciones de bailén con el gobierno
saudí son francamente malas su
administración está apoyando la creación
de una especie de nueva alianza militar
que incluye además de varios países
árabes al estado de israel es decir que
hablamos de un fortalecimiento del peso
la influencia y las relaciones de eeuu
como hacía décadas no conocíamos sin
embargo un momento porque pese a ello la
popularidad de joe vaivén está más fría
que un témpano de hielo en plena
antártida y la pregunta la gran pregunta
es cómo demonios es esto posible qué
diantres explica que la popularidad del
presidente se había desplomado de
semejante forma
[Música]
pues queridos amigos amigas la respuesta
quizás tenga que ver con las constantes
meteduras de pata como cuando dijo que
tenía cáncer y la casa blanca le tuvo
que desmentir sus rostros y no usar
lugar fueron the wheels uruguay cristie
kerr número y digo soy con windows
mensual el sol de medio de fútbol
europeo quieren ser o puede que
directamente tenga que ver con que el
presidente es evidente que está mayor
muy mayor lo que entre otras cosas le
hace incapaz de vender sus logros pero
honestamente creo que también tiene que
ver con esto
así es hablamos de lo que podemos
calificar como el gran fracaso del baile
no mix porque querida comunidad de
visual político cuando joe biden ganó
las elecciones no sólo prometió una
regeneración institucional también
prometió dar un giro de 180 grados a la
política económica para que el gobierno
federal volviera a liderar la
reconstrucción de los eeuu de américa
incluso hubo quien describió la llegada
de bailén como la puesta en marcha de un
nuevo paradigma económico que pondría
fin de una vez por todas a la américa
basada en los bajos impuestos el estado
pequeño y la desregulación de ronald
reagan como si algo así siguiera
existiendo y no penséis que tan solo fue
algo exógeno el propio entorno de bailén
defendió que su llegada al poder
conllevaría algo prácticamente
equivalente al new deal de roosevelt
tras la gran depresión del 29
de esta forma durante la campaña
electoral maiden hablo de cosas como
recuperar el peso sindical luchar
decididamente contra el cambio climático
cancelar la deuda estudiantil o ordenar
el caos migratorio o reconstruir las
viejas infraestructuras
norteamericanas y sobre todo habló y
mucho de estimular la inversión la
privada y sobre todo y liderando la
nueva economía la inversión pública así
que en cierto modo podemos decir que
cambio de paradigma o no lo que sí que
prometió claramente yo vaivén fue
reconstruir eeuu con una agenda muy
demócrata
[Música]
sin embargo desde entonces desde
entonces los resultados no han sido
exactamente los esperados en algunos
casos porque los proyectos se han
estancado o han terminado en casi nada y
en otros porque bueno creo que los
titulares hablan por sí solos 13 de
julio de 2022 estados unidos la
inflación del 9,1 por ciento registró en
junio un nuevo máximo en 40 años
25 de julio de 2022 los datos muestran
que la economía de eeuu se tambalea ante
la recesión pero en qué ha fallado
exactamente el baile no mix que no está
funcionando con la actual política de la
casa blanca que está provocando que los
norteamericanos suspendan rotundamente
al actual presidente pues bien veámoslo
[Música]
una revolución a medio gas
la presidencia de william comenzó con
una actividad frenética pero al final
terminada la primera mitad del 2022 esta
administración había conseguido
básicamente tan solo tres cosas con su
nueva política económica un plan de
lucha contra el commit más pequeño que
el de trump y que se convirtió en
auténtica gasolina para inflación un
incremento mediante órdenes y directivas
presidenciales del gasto del gobierno
durante la próxima década de
530.000 millones de dólares un
incremento fundamentalmente destinado a
mejorar el conocido como programa de
asistencia nutricional suplementaria un
plan de cupones para familias de bajos
ingresos y por último y tercero un
proyecto bipartito de infraestructuras
mucho más pequeño de lo que había
prometido
luego todo hay que decirlo a finales de
julio de 2022 la administración baiden
ganó por sorpresa los votos para sacar
adelante el conocido como proyecto de
ley de reducción de la inflación una ley
que contempla varias subidas de
impuestos entre ellas el pago mínimo del
15 por ciento sobre beneficios o una
ampliación sin precedentes del sistema
de recaudación fiscal también cientos de
miles de millones de dólares en nuevo
gasto por ejemplo
385 mil millones se destinarán a
combatir el cambio climático impulsar el
coche eléctrico y reforzar la producción
de energías limpias aún así la ley es
apenas una fracción de la promesa
inicial de la administración y
prácticamente todas las demás políticas
del vaivén o mick han encallado y
teniendo en cuenta la bajísima
popularidad del presidente y la mejor
intención de voto de los republicanos no
parece que esta revolución sin gas pueda
ir mucho más allá y con la presente
administración y con una próxima
claro a ver quién es el guapo que se
atreve a [ __ ] semejante cuchillo
cayendo al vacío por supuesto esto no
quiere decir que la presidencia de baile
haya terminado ni mucho menos
[Música]
la situación internacional ha puesto en
el centro de la diana a la política
exterior y como ya hemos comentado ahí
la administración vaivén está de todo
menos quieta sin embargo en lo que
respecta a la política económica hay el
suspenso aparece más que probable y para
colmo puede que lo peor para la
popularidad del presidente no esté
haciendo sino comenzar
26 de julio de 2022 una encuesta de la
cnc muestra que la mayoría de los
inversores y economistas consideran que
las subidas de tipos de la reserva
federal- causarán una recesión en el
plazo de un año pero más allá de lo que
no ha podido sacar adelante la pregunta
que podemos hacernos es en qué se ha
equivocado exactamente joe biden atentos
[Música]
lo que americano necesitaba
queridos amigos amigas básicamente el
presidente y su equipo diagnosticaron
mal la situación de la economía
norteamericana ya partir de ahí todo fue
en cierto modo de mal en peor un ejemplo
lo tenemos con el plan de choque contra
la pandemia de bailén que vertió decenas
y decenas cientos de miles de millones
sobre la economía norteamericana cuando
ésta se estaba ya recuperando mucho más
rápido de lo previsto el resultado
gasolina sobre una hoguera de inflación
galopante
[Música]
y eso no es todo por ejemplo dentro del
plan anterior destacó un crédito fiscal
prácticamente universal y según el caso
pagadero en efectivo y hasta 300 dólares
mensuales por niño una iniciativa que la
administración de joe biden pensó sería
recibida con los brazos abiertos por la
ciudadanía norteamericana lo que les
permitiría consolidar la de forma
permanente pues bien nada más lejos de
la realidad apenas un tercio de los
estadounidenses apoyan que esta política
sea permanente lo que por supuesto
permitió que los republicanos decidieran
que no votarían para su renovación más
allá del primer año según una encuesta
sólo 1 de cada 3 norteamericanos quieren
que la ampliación de los créditos
fiscales por hijos sea permanente
pensando bien porque apoyar que el
gobierno entregue permanentemente
cheques de efectivo en un contexto en el
que hay mucho trabajo disponible y
salarios crecientes sea como sea lo que
está claro es que una de las medidas
estrella de esta administración no
consiguió hacerse con la simpatía
general pero lo que sí que hizo fue
costar mucho dinero e incrementar la
deuda pública alimentar aún más
en esta misma línea el diagnóstico de
que el américa más pobre se estaba
quedando atrás y que por tanto
necesitaba que el gobierno promoviera
nuevos empleos simple y llanamente no
era cierto de hecho desde el 2010 han
sido precisamente los salarios más bajos
los que más han estado creciendo así que
más esfuerzos más dinero y nuevas
regulaciones tiradas por la borda
y luego tenemos los impuestos la
obsesión de esta administración está
siendo subir los impuestos a las
empresas supuestamente a los más ricos
el problema es que por ejemplo las
subidas del impuesto sobre los
beneficios de las empresas del 21 al 28
por ciento defendida por joe biden no
sólo haría que eeuu volviera a tener uno
de los tipos impositivos más elevados de
todo el mundo desarrollado sino que
además contribuiría a frenar la
inversión de las empresas ralentizar la
economía e incrementar los costes de
producción exactamente lo que no hay que
hacer en tiempos de inflación
[Música]
para colmo otra cosa que no tuvieron en
cuenta los demócratas es que en los
últimos años ha vuelto a elevarse el
porcentaje de familias que tienen
invertido sus ahorros y sus planes de
pensiones en la bolsa familias a las que
por supuesto medidas como ésta no les
hace ninguna gracia 12 de mayo de 2022
galope encuentran su encuesta de
economía y finanzas personales de abril
que el 58% de los estadounidenses pues
en acciones esta cifra es ligeramente
superior al 56 por ciento de 2021 al 55
por ciento de 2020 asumiendo bailén ha
impulsado una política económica basada
en grandes planes de gasto público
incrementos de impuestos que la sociedad
no necesitaba y la sociedad no quería y
que ni siquiera era conveniente dado el
contexto económico una política que
además ha terminado por impulsar la
mayor inflación de los últimos 40 años
lo que a su vez obligado a reaccionar a
la fed a la reserva federal lo que
parece que va a terminar con la economía
norteamericana entrando en recesión el
gobierno dilapidando cientos de miles de
millones de dólares y las familias
perdiendo poder adquisitivo vamos que la
cosa no podía haber salido peor al menos
vista de la popularidad del valle no mix
y espera de momento porque no aún no
hemos terminado
[Música]
otro de los grandes cambios prometidos
por la administración vaivén tiene que
ver con la transición energética y la
lucha contra el cambio climático algo
que la verdad ya de entrada con los
datos en la mano cómo decirlo no genera
precisamente mucho entusiasmo entre el
público estadounidense particularmente
en momentos como este fijaos sólo el 1
por ciento de los votantes menciona el
cambio climático como el problema más
importante que enfrenta el país muy por
detrás de las preocupaciones sobre la
inflación y la economía incluso entre
los votantes menores de 30 años el grupo
que se pensó que estaba más motivado por
el tema esa cifra fue del 3% david
wallace wells columnista del new york
times' sea como sea la cuestión es que
el equipo de bailén puso la industria
petrolera en el centro de su diana nada
más llegar a la casa blanca el
presidente comenzó a emitir una tras
otra órdenes ejecutivas contra la
industria del petróleo
de esta forma entre otras medidas el
presidente de byd en paralizar las
explotaciones en el refugio nacional de
vida silvestre del ártico canceló la
construcción del oleoducto kissed onix
con canadá ordenó a las agencias del
gobierno estudiar nuevas reglas para
frenar el consumo congelar permisos
subir los impuestos y reducir la
financiación de las compañías petroleras
e incluso estableció una moratoria al
arrendamiento de tierras federales para
buscar y explotar petróleo todas estas
medidas no sólo buscaban castigar a la
industria del petróleo norteamericana
sino que sobre todo pretendían enviar un
mensaje muy claro al mercado el que no
merecía la pena invertir grandes
cantidades de dinero en el sector
petrolero porque el gobierno lo iba a
castigar
[Música]
visto lo visto craso error todas estas
políticas que hemos visto supusieron
dopar la demanda que al mismo tiempo
dañar la oferta justo cuando la economía
se estaba recuperando a toda velocidad
es posible que sin las acciones de
bailén las cosas no habrían sido muy
diferentes o quizás sí lo que está claro
es que el baile no mix ha ido en la
dirección equivocada y que se ha
convertido en uno de los grandes
culpables de los desequilibrios
económicos que hoy castigan a las
familias norteamericanas porque amigos
amigas maiden si podría haber hecho
muchas cosas atentos
[Música]
lo que américa si necesita
si bailén quería mejorar el nivel de
vida de las familias estadounidenses su
prioridad tendría que haber sido todas
maneras medidas para promover la
inversión tanto pública como privada en
el caso de la inversión pública lo hemos
contado en nuestro boletín de patrón el
problema es que el gobierno federal cada
vez gasta más cada vez invierte menos es
decir la inmensa mayor parte de todo el
presupuesto se destina a gasto
asistencial o no productivo de esta
forma en lugar de invertir en
investigación o infraestructuras como
las autopistas interestatales o la presa
hoover el gasto se ha trasladado en su
mayor parte al bienestar social la
defensa y el servicio de la deuda fijaos
si sumamos el gasto en defensa y el pago
a individuos salarios subsidios y rentas
de todo tipo entonces podemos explicar
el 85,4 por ciento de todo el gasto
federal en comparación con el 71 2% que
representaba en 1990 esto quiere decir
que a pesar de los grandes déficits
públicos el desembolso en el resto de
parte como infraestructuras exploración
espacial o y más demás y está siendo
aplastado es decir que la inversión
pública cada vez es en proporción más
pequeña
[Música]
y para colmo la inversión neta de las
empresas norteamericanas también ha
venido cayendo desde hace casi 40 años
fijaos
e intentar cambiar esta tendencia con
políticas de oferta habría contribuido
decisivamente a frenar la inflación y
mejorar el poder adquisitivo de las
familias norteamericanas a largo plazo
pero dentro del bayern no mix todo esto
era la parte más pequeña en definitiva
si el desempleo se encuentra
prácticamente en su menor nivel desde el
69 pero no ocurre lo mismo con las tasas
de empleo cuya recuperación está siendo
mucho más lenta y eso por no olvidar que
por culpa de la enorme inflación los
salarios reales están contrayéndose lo
que explica que el sentimiento del
consumidor sea casi tan bajo como lo fue
durante la gran crisis del 2008
[Música]
y qué significa esto pues que hoy por
hoy quizás sin mucho motivo los
consumidores estadounidenses son
pesimistas sobre el futuro próximo y lo
son en gran medida porque entienden que
el baile no mix no ha funcionado para
nada digamos que no importa que los
fundamentales de la economía
norteamericana padezcan robustos vaivén
llegó con un plan que no ha contribuido
sino a empeorar las cosas y amigos
amigas esta es una de las razones que
explican la baja popularidad de joe
biden así que no importa que su
administración esté cosechando muchos
tantos en política exterior si el
panorama económico no cambia la
presidencia de bailén no pasará a la
historia como una presidencia popular
pero hecho esto turno para ti qué
opinión te merece el bar ya no mix crees
que la actual administración está a
tiempo de cambiar de marcha y conseguir
mejores resultados crees que se está
siendo excesivamente injustos con ella
déjanos para que bajo tus comentarios y
abramos debate y por supuesto si este
vídeo te pareció interesante olvides
darle al botón de like suscribirte a
visual político nos vemos en el próximo
vídeo y también en la liga visual
polític de wenger te lo dejamos también
en los comentarios muchas gracias por
estar ahí un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]